what we're doing tonight we're going
around and we're gonna hit the street
tonight we're setting up vigils for
fallen Pokemon we're going to actual
gyms and retreat in the losses like the
real
we are going to have these pop up all
over the country and the thought is if
we start to make this thing will become
a thing people are so into it you know
really this is to you know pay homage to
all the pokemon that you invest all the
time in and train and get their CP up
and then all of a sudden boom there it
is they fall and you've lost and you're
out we give people a way to mourn their
losses are they going to actually fight
is this going to become an earnest
movement this is a worldwide phenomenon
and we're all invested in this by the
way we know they don't die but they do
fall hashtag all right Pokemon